first of all
that's megan stallion in shock over
beyonce joining her on stage to accept
their 2021 grammy for best rap song for
the remix of savage
i told ferris i'm gonna bring my paper
up here this time because i'm not gonna
forget
to thank nobody and now you're saying
came up here
yep she was basically speechless and
it was kind of adorable i definitely
want to say thank you
to beyonce
if you know me you have to know
ever since i was little i was like you
know what one day i'm gonna grow up and
i'm gonna be like the rap beyonce
that was definitely my goal and i
remember i went to the rodeo for the
first time and i saw destiny's child
perform
and i was like you know what yes i'm
about to go hard i love her work ethic
i love the way she is i love the way she
carried herself she also made this
hilarious joke my mama will always be
like megan
what would beyonce do and i'm always
like you know what
what would be else i do but let me make
it a little ratchet
beyonce also shared some words megan i
have so much respect for you
and i'm honored that you asked me to be
a part of the song and i just want to
say houston we love you thank you
grammys thank you
did you have any idea beyonce was
sitting down there literally
i looked and i was like is that beyonce
that's beyonce
so every time i see beyonce i get
excited like i've never seen her before
what how cool was that that she was
there to have that moment with you
it was just such an epic moment um
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just love
absolutely love beyonce and to have her
like just
seal the deal for me like it's like a
pat on the back like i am proud of you
girl i'm like
thank you and she set a record tonight
how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
black women in general we here we're
here to stay
we're here to take over we've been doing
that but
like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight
yes beyonce now holds the record for
most
grammys for a performer ever e.t also
spoke with megan after she and bee
won their first award of the night
together for best rap performance
for two girls from houston two girls
grew up with a dream
and now you have this song that like
when it when that remix hit
it exploded exploded it was like the
world
shifted or something everybody would
always ask me in every interview i ever
did who do you want to do a song with
what would you what would be your dream
feature and i'll be like beyonce beyonce
every interview i spoke that into
existence
so when i finally got it i was like
y'all i got a song will be honest i had
to call my grandma we was both crying
you